hello and welcome to video playing
o'clock from Sweden oh actually it was
stupid I'm playing Knight c3 Knight f6
Bishop g5 mostly simply because i don't
like this variation okay let's see I
simply don't like that I think to get
more vitus to play some kind of you for
early end this is not my kind of chair
zone huh hmm what you do now check kima
ok I thought t5 is very undesirable for
black but he played immediately Wow
writes very ambitious let's see let's
see
c4 immediately I know maybe this is too
much he have quasi play the most
ambitious move in a second d40 x f4
maybe something crazy probably and obvi
should be six know yeah it was a very
aggressive move but I just drop back I'm
not sure that this Nets much maybe I
mean just politics this is just good for
white I think maybe you can take weather
99 takes really can take with the 19
this pollution and I he goes at four and
playing alter aggressively yeah it's
maybe possible it's absolutely not out
of the picture my bishops look very
strange now you know
mm that's absolutely correct equity he
can absolutely play like this my piece
is also look quite silly so a super
bishops play worked perfectly
you
well pretty bad position one castles
just g3 is this amazing
he might have 33 already takes Queen III
check 33 maybe I go bishop ever g1 done
a bishop g1 is probably still ok but
it's immensely scary and the other idea
that black certainly can go for is to a
song they just like move the night and
play for Bishop f5 also you can just
take c-5m yeah this is a good move i
guess just going for the trade
it's pretty awful black can just take
take the porn on f 2 this is not the
only way to play it certainly better for
black yep and he took it okay shrine to
tempt them to take this as well and then
Bishop c5 which doesn't do much
admittedly but I need some help here for
before black anyway I es got Queen to c6
also quite quite quickly
yeah now he takes ages what's the deal
okay it's giving up the exchange which
is certainly playable it wasn't
necessary for sure but it was all the
action okay I mean his pawns are quick
but I think I also have some play there
on the queenside and they are really
quick okay
probably that too quick
and 93 is also a threat Bow Wow
f3 is really tough
time morning okay it was probably lost
anyway but I wonder what I did anyway f
three wins here pretty straightforwardly
and test double threaten of the check 93
check and the promotion white resigns
they are probably the pawns are too
strong him incoming challenge of course
not this is something that I really hate
and they they do a rematch out of after
playing the five-minute pool anyway and
yeah okay i'm not an expert on all this
but let's be I surprised it you've
played this lock instantly it's of
course exactly what the engine
recommends so probably it is strong I
felt this very loose on that diagonal of
it maybe not yeah probably it's got a
good position here it's got a good
center and I have no way of using this
diagonal which would scare me with black
but anti-d for was too strong Teague's f
force is very strong yeah here g3 also
came into consideration which already
winds and the 94 wins and as this is
winning Wow
so it was a big opening disaster yeah I
tried to muddy the waters but you just
returned the exchange yeah and this is
probably just losing I thought I have
some counter play with the sea porn
after winning the bee pollen there is no
color he just just promotes this so you
just promotes this mmm yeah I don't know
yeah probably this Bishop c4 isn't a
good idea and I'm also a bit a bit angry
because i have replaced Bishop g5 with
this line but simply forgot to play it
because i don't i somehow i don't like
this stuff there is a form but this
leads to very weird complication that I
simply don't understand this is why I go
III and then we get this position ID I'm
always getting outplayed I don't know
what it is but I am probably playing
they're probably playing this an end
totally wrong way but um yeah I don't
want to play this line anymore i just
stumbled into this by accident again
paying too quickly still strange that
all this is good yeah yeah probably it
is the set there is a bit a bit too
strong this looks shaky but there's no
way to exploit it okay well thanks for
watching